-We're talking about romantic comedies tonight. It's great.
-It's a real rom-com kind of night!
-I love that. -I like it.
-I love a romantic comedy. But do you --
When you're writing this, do you go,
"Oh, something like this kind of happened in my life.
I'll put this into the movie"? -A little bit.
I mean, you know, the main premise of the movie
is not about us, luckily,
but we put a lot of little details into it, for sure.
And, like, Dave's a romantic guy,
so we certainly had some situations early on,
you know, when we first started dating.
We spent the first, like, six weeks of our relationship
in different cities.
He was shooting a movie called "Now You See Me."
And so we met -- [ Audience oohs ]
Alright! Some magic fans in the audience.
So, we met in New Orleans during Mardi Gras
when he was shooting that. And then the movie took him to New York,
and we kind of re-met up in New York.
And he was going to finish shooting the movie in Paris.
So, while we're in New York, he hides a little --
My last day in New York, he hides a little note in my shoe.
And when I'm putting my shoe on, I get this little note.
And it says, "Meet me in Paris."
And there's a little drawing
of two stick figures and the Eiffel Tower.
-What? -So then I'm going to go
to Paris and I tell my friends,
"I'm meeting this new guy I'm seeing in Paris."
And they're like, "You've got to go to this bridge,
the Pont des Arts.
People put their initials on locks
and they lock it on the bridge,
and it means they're going to be together forever.
And they throw the keys into the Seine!"
-yeah. -I was like --
-Throw the key.
-"Slow your roll. I just met this guy."
-Yeah, I'm not locking my love with this guy.
-Yeah. Also, like, I don't need to put that message out to him.
Like, let me try to be cool and aloof a little bit.
-Yeah, smart. -So, we get to Paris.
We're walking around one day. It's raining.
Dave gives me his jacket. So sweet.
-Yeah. -I put my hand in the pocket
and pull out a little lock that has our initials on it.
And I looked at him and was like,
"[ Gasps ] You like me! Oh, my God!"
-Here's -- Here's the -- -We locked it on the bridge.
-Here it is.
-And we've been together ever since.
[ Cheers and applause ] -Are you kidding me?
That's the most romantic thing in the world.
-I mean, he's in love with me. -I love that.
Do -- Do you go -- Have you ever been back to visit the bridge?
-We did go back, and I guess the locks
were, like, sagging down the whole bridge
and compromising its inherent nature as a bridge
and they cut -- they cut all the locks off.
They put up big fencing
so nobody can put a lock on ever again.
-Oh, my God. Are you kidding me?
-Yeah, so I guess we're going to get divorced.
-No, that's not what it meant. No.
That -- No. This love is here to stay.
-We have to. We have the photo. We have the photo.
-You have the photo. Yeah. Love lives forever.
-Okay. Yes, yes! [ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's -- I want to talk about the movie and -- and the plot
of the movie "Somebody I Used to Know."
-Yes. -But since you're always
down for a game and something fun on our show,
I thought it would be fun if you
would like to freestyle a rap what the movie is about.
-You've done this to me before.
[ Laughter ]
-It makes me -- -You've done this to me before.
-It makes me laugh. It makes me laugh.
It -- But, I mean. Here's wh-- You're not a rapper.
-Look, I'm not a rapper.
So let's just say that before we do anything else.
-'Cause everyone thought that when you came out.
Everyone's like, "Oh, Alison Brie, the rapper."
-The rapper. I know. I'm known in certain circles.
But just to dispel that rumor -- -So you are not a rapper.
But would you like to -- -I will do the honors tonight.
-Wow. -If you guys wanna --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Quest will drop a beat.
♪♪
Oh. Alright. I'm feeling it. Okay.
And we're about to go in 3, 2, 1.
Here it comes.
♪ Here's a little tale about a movie I made ♪
♪ With my sweet-ass husband, his name is Dave ♪
♪ About girl meets boy or re-meets actually ♪
♪ I don't want to start off this rap infactually ♪
♪ So they hang out in their hometown ♪
♪ And they have a great night just paling around ♪
♪ And she's totally in, she thinks he's the one ♪
♪ But that's when things stop being fun ♪
♪ See, it turns out he's hearing wedding bells ♪
♪ But they're not about her, they're about someone else ♪
-Ohh! -♪ What's gonna happen? ♪
♪ Where could this go? ♪
♪ You're gonna have to watch "Somebody I Used to Know" ♪
-Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ] Come on, now!
That's exactly -- That is how you do it right there!
Alison Brie! I want to show a clip.
Here's Alison Brie in "Somebody I Used to Know."
Take a look.
♪♪
-Ally?
-Sean. Oh, my God.
-Were you just hiding under the table?
-Was I hid-- No, no.
I was just -- I was looking for my, uh, peanut.
Got it. Ah.
Well, this is crazy. What are you doing here?
-Yeah. I was just about to ask you the same thing.
-You know, I'm just visiting my old haunts on the off-chance
I might run into an ex from ten years ago.
-Oh, yeah? How many have you run into so far?
-Yeah. Alison Brie!
"Somebody I Used to Know"
is available this Friday on Prime Video.